from day one shemar Moore's Derek Morgan
was the charm and muscle at the heart of
Criminal Minds he made it through 11
seasons barely that included wrestling
with bad guys and childhood demons not
to mention being framed kidnapped and
tortured finally enough was enough for
both the character and the actor who
played him more officially departed from
the long-running crime drama on March
23rd 2016 in an episode that saw his
character's fiancee survived a gunshot
wound and give birth to their child and
that was just two episodes after
Morgan's own near-death experience
suffice to say that having a baby
changed Morgan's perspective on his
career and he decided to step away from
the action-packed life and his
colleagues in the Behavioral Analysis
Unit
since then Moore has returned to both
CBS and the role of crime fighting
action hero with a troubled past playing
Hondo on SWAT but despite his talent for
playing tough guys who won't say no to a
fight in real life Moore's reasons for
bidding farewell to his most famous role
are surprisingly similar to Morgan's
reasons for leaving the BAU it took
eight years for flirtatious workaholic
Morgan to find a steady girlfriend as
more put it - TV Guide
you never saw Morgan's off-the-clock
side where he lets his hair down dates
has drinks and has somebody in his life
in the first episode of season 9 the
character finally mentioned a girlfriend
but it took another eight episodes to
meet the lucky lady who had become his
fiancee Savannah a doctor at Bethesda
General Hospital Moore can relate to his
characters overdue love life in fact
that's one reason he gave for stepping
away from the role a few months after
his last episode aired
he told TV Guide that he said goodbye to
Criminal Minds so I could pursue other
avenues of my life I want to get married
I want to have kids I want to travel a
few years on and it appears that unlike
Morgan Moore has yet to find the person
he wants to settle down with
he's been romantically linked to several
famous women since leaving Criminal
Minds including soccer player Shana
Gordon who he dated from 2014 to 2015
and actress Annabel Acosta in 2018
he told Steve Harvey that he and Acosta
were taking things slow while also
emphasizing that he was looking for a
long-term partner saying I've done
everything I could do by myself and now
I need that somebody I need that partner
in crime to do the rest of what I want
to do unfortunately Acosta was not that
partner the pair split in 2019 and
Moore's mission to find love continues
the other reason Moore gave for leaving
Criminal Minds was both personal and
professional in that same TV Guide chat
he revealed I'm just ready to grow
I'm not leaving to make a bunch of money
I'm leaving because I just creatively
want to be fueled and I'm excited to try
new things and see what else I'm capable
of after departing from Criminal Minds
more starred in the 2016 rom-com the
bounce-back which he also executive
produced the film looked like it might
be more Stansted the mold as he went
from portraying an FBI special agent to
playing an unlucky and loved self-styled
relationship expert the bounce-back
received respectable reviews from
critics and audiences but it ultimately
flew under the radar and didn't make
much of an impact for more the actor
also continued lending his voice to the
character of Victor stone aka cyborg
across several animated DC projects
which he had done even when he was still
working on Criminal Minds good work team
to badge is an Atlanta net list of fun
in 2017 Moore went back to television
for SWAT a remake of ABC's short-lived
70s cop series that is still going
strong as of the making of this video
Moore told CBS this morning in October
2017 that his role on SWAT is his dream
job this is my dream job because I've
always believed what I'm capable of I
get to be a lead which I'm proud of but
I'm also smart enough and humble enough
to know that I can't do it by myself
it is certainly sad to see more leave
Criminal Minds but fans can take heart
knowing that he's happy where he is now
and will likely be a prime-time mainstay
for years to come check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]